hi welcome to the date of science with
statistical analysis system or SAS
course offered by simply learned in this
video you'll see some interesting
highlights of this course have you faced
challenges during data processing
because of the size of the data have you
felt the need to combine separate
compare and extract data based on a
specific requirement as interpreting
data been difficult because you couldn't
manipulate it have you ever wanted to
learn the most in-demand analytics
technology SAS can help you achieve all
this and more it offers a variety of
data analysis tool that can deal with
large data SAS provides and into in
solution for the entire analytic cycle
it's the undisputed leader in the
commercial analytic space SAS is an
integrated system of software solutions
which enables you to perform the
following tasks data entry retrieval and
management report writing and graphics
designer
statistical and mathematical analysis
business forecasting and decision
support operations research and project
management applications development data
science is concerned with organizing
packing and delivering data SAS can help
in all three stages with the tools at
their disposal in SAS data scientists
can organize analyze and provide
interpretations or results SAS has an
edge over other tools with its huge
array of statistical functions
user-friendly graphical user interface
and technical support industries that
use tests include automotive banking
capital markets consumer goods defense
health care higher education
manufacturing media retail sports
entertainment and so on demand for SAS
professionals has increased dramatically
compared to other data analysis software
professionals if you are someone who is
interested in the field of data science
and analytics then this course is ideal
for you all you need is an analytical
bent of mind and the rest is taken care
of
by the data science with class course it
covers the essentials of statistical
techniques and basics of programming
using this tool simply learns data
science Swift as course will enable you
to understand the role of data scientist
use the SAS tool apply data manipulation
and optimization techniques work on
advanced statistical concepts like
clustering linear regression and
decision trees apply data analysis
methods to real-world business problems
understand and apply predictive modeling
techniques this course enables you to
learn the key concepts of SAS which are
important for data analytics using
practical examples let's start this
lesson by defining what statistical
analysis system is statistical analysis
system or SAS is a software suite
developed by the SAS Institute for
advanced analytics multivariate analyses
business intelligence data management
and predictive analytics SAS is a set of
solutions for enterprise wide business
users and it provides a powerful force
generation programming language for
performing tasks such as data entry
retrieval and management statistical and
mathematical analysis business planning
forecasting and decision support
operations research and project
management and quality improvement
before we begin with the concepts of SAS
let's install the SAS university edition
in your system SAS University Edition is
a free version to practice SAS
programming language you can download
the free SAS university edition by
visiting the website shown on the screen
ensure you have the following system
configuration to install the software
64-bit hardware one gigabyte of RAM
Windows 7 8 8.1 or 10 Microsoft's
Internet Explorer 9 10 or 11 Mozilla
Firefox 21 or later or Google Chrome 27
or later version this installation steps
is also available in the link shown on
the screen
follow the installation steps carefully
and enjoy working on the SAS software
now that you have installed the sass
University addition in your system let's
see how to open the SAS software follow
these steps to open the SAS university
edition open VirtualBox by double
clicking its icon on the desktop
to access the SAS university edition
VirtualBox opens Oracle VM ware
VirtualBox
type the link shown on the screen in
your Internet Explorer Mozilla Firefox
or Google Chrome
you
now you can access the sass University
edition Information Center click start
SAS studio the SAS studio opens in a new
window there you have it you now have
access to SAS and can start practicing
this new programming language attention
people simply learn provides an exciting
range of learning modules for our eager
learners SAS being a statistical course
simply learned provides content with
visualization to enhance learning takes
you on the syntax classroom to teach you
the coding once to hold your attention
by providing logical breaks in the form
of knowledge checks and provides
hands-on experience with demos
assignments and practice sessions going
one step further simply learn introduces
gaming to add an element of challenge to
your learning learn while you play
organize to analyze the course comprises
32 hours of instructor-led training 24
hours of e-learning and hands-on
experience with industry projects you'll
receive full support from the simply
learn faculty throughout the course and
mentoring for project work you'll also
be able to access three sets of
assessment papers and for live industry
projects on the SAS tool unsuccessful
completion you'll receive an experience
certificate to complete data science
with class certification you'll need to
complete any one project and get them
evaluated by the lead trainer score at
least 80% on the online exam submit your
queries by writing to help and support
on WW simply learn calm or talking
directly to our support staff with the
simply talk and live chat options
Hey want to become an expert in Big Data
then subscribe to the simply learn
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos centered up and get
certified in Big Data click here